The moment they learned that sao had become a real death game,
people went mad. They cursed their fate for not being able to participate, and
went on a rampage without grief
.
I wonder if he cried and raged for a while and calmed down
After that, he pushed on with his work.
Now he's quite successful. Mr. 1 is the company president or something
.  I put everything I
had into it and played it over and over
Didn't a game where you really don't die didn't make her home burst from the depths of her heart
?  After two years of working and playing VR games, the
sa incident was resolved.
It seems that
there was a player killer, and that there was such a guild, but it was
n't
a murder.It seems that there were some players who found their purpose in killing other characters.
A considerable number of players would
have been killed
if you include Shinji.
Two chagrins dominated her, one was that she could have beaten them to death in the name of justice
.